hi everyone sal here from khan academy
welcome to our homeroom live stream very
excited about the conversation we're
about to have with lester holt uh before
we jump into that conversation i will
make a few of my standard announcements
uh one uh just a reminder to folks that
khan academy is a not-for-profit if
you're in a position to do so please
think about making a donation that can
be done at khan academy.org
donate i also want to give special
thanks to several organizations that
stepped up over the last a couple of
months when they saw that we were
already running under the deficit
pre-covered and that the deficit only
grew as uh we saw 300 of the traffic we
normally see as all of the folks are are
leaning on us for uh as we figure out
distance learning together a special
thanks to bank of america google.org att
fastly novartis and the amgen family
foundation amgen foundation not the
family foundation i also want to
announce uh i announced this on a
previous live stream
that we're taking select versions of
this live stream and turning them into a
podcast so if you want to
you know watch or maybe you shouldn't be
watching if you want to listen to this
maybe while you're in the car or some
other place we're taking a subset of our
conversations editing them a little bit
for podcast and making them available so
you can anywhere you uh you can get your
your podcast uh hopefully you'll see the
homeroom with sal
shortly
so with that i'm really excited and
honored uh to introduce someone that
you're probably already familiar with
someone who you've probably already seen
in your home
lester holt anchor of the nbc nightly
news with lester holt uh lester thanks
so much for for joining us happy to join
you sal and uh yes people watch me at
home and and it's basically from my home
to their home these days
yeah i think there's something nice
about that you know yeah i know you know
it's above my pay grade but you might
want to continue this uh it's very
intimate in a nice way
well you know they it's it's a lot more
responsibility than i'm used to normally
i go into a big studio and i don't think
about cameras and sound and lighting and
all that stuff now i do and uh you know
now my big fear is tripping over a plug
which has been done uh and threatening
our signal out of here but uh you know
it's
i always tell people that as a
international news organization we're
used to taking the broadcast on the road
to far-flung corners of the world in
hospitable places so in many ways this
wasn't a huge challenge for us but
in a sustaining way to do our broadcast
like this uh has been uh it's been
interesting and i certainly missed the
you know face-to-face collaboration with
my colleagues
i i can imagine i mean you're doing it
at much higher stakes before i even do
this live stream i i go through my house
yelling get off a live stream get off of
netflix i'm about to
get off a zoom everybody so i could have
been
i have a dog
that occasionally piped in and then last
week i was watching my
grandson's and the one year old i'm on
the phone he runs into my little
makeshift studio and of all the things
he touches it's the button that could
knock me off the air and i look on the
screen and it says do you really wish to
disconnect i'm like no so it's
always something everyone's going
through it on some level
no it's really interesting and so
there's a bunch of stuff i'm i'm excited
to talk to you about and i do want to
encourage anyone watching
on facebook or youtube or social media
generally every now and then it shows up
in other places i didn't expect put
questions and we have team members who
are going to surface uh the questions uh
for uh lester and myself if it's
relevant uh and and maybe a good place
to start which i think is really
exciting because we have a lot of young
people watching this and a lot of
parents who watch this is
not only are you the anchor of the nbc
nightly news you're also the anchor of
the nbc nightly news kids edition which
is available
online if someone were to search that
look it up which which i love i've
actually watched many many episodes of
it tell us why why you did this and what
what this is
well this was early on in in the
pandemic and you know things were going
south very quickly we were all being
overwhelmed and i remember doing the
newscast every night and thinking you
know there are families watching this
right now and the numbers and the
stories we're telling are grim and these
video diaries and these healthcare
workers
and you're one of the other uh
producers on the broadcast said you know
maybe we should do a kids show geared
toward them and we all looked at each
other like of course that's exactly what
we should be doing so
it started out very organic just a
handful of folks kind of scrapping the
other uh and trying to know learn as we
go along about a way to present some of
this very heavy stuff with this pandemic
uh to kids in in a digestible way i mean
you know kids aren't stupid they're
they're watching what's going on around
them they're seeing the confusion and
distress among the adults and we wanted
to you know do it in bite sizes so we've
kept that up and we've tried to also
move along with the news so of course we
covered you know the uh um some of the
protests the black lives matter movement
and you know things happening in space
and and other things that might be of
interest uh of specific interest to kids
and we like to feature kids too some of
the inspiring things that they're doing
how they've you know figuring out ways
to learn at home and just kind of adapt
uh to our reality
no and i'll once again say it's really
interesting and i've actually been very
impressed you take questions from kids
and the questions that they ask are
oftentimes
better some of what you see in the you
know the experts asking on uh on the
adult on
on on on television generally you know i
think one of the really interesting
things
that a lot of folks wonder you know and
i used to wonder this when i would see a
lester holt on tv
uh how did you become lester holt how do
you how do you become kind of this
trusted you know go-to person for a
whole country or for the world
you know did you think you were going to
do this when you were a teenager when
you were younger or what you know
there's a question here from new permit
on youtube you know what were your
struggles you encountered a lot of
people think it's you know i wanted to
do it and then it just happened all of a
sudden i'd love to hear a little bit
about your journey
um things just unfolded for me i did
want to be in broadcasting from a very
early age i had an older brother eight
years older than me who had a brief
stint in radio and you know he took me
down to the radio station one day and i
thought this is very very cool and so
that's what i i really wanted to do was
radio and be a dj
uh at the age of 17 during my senior
year in high school i got a job at a
country and western radio station in
sacramento california
midnight to six on saturdays and sundays
uh you know playing records and you know
reading the news every hour uh at the
same time i was got an internship um it
wasn't even a real internship because i
was still in high school but i managed
to kind of talk my way in to the nbc
station in sacramento the tv station
kcra and kind of hung around there and
helped out in the public affairs
department and just trying to soak up as
much as i could uh started college did
two years into college and landed a job
in san francisco at an all news radio
station so i dropped out
never went back um kids don't do what i
do don't do what i do but uh you know
life kind of worked out did radio um
went to new york uh when i was 22 maybe
yeah about 22
and
landed a job at the
cbs tv station here then stayed with cbs
went to uh los angeles and back to new
york and chicago
uh all in local news and then came to
msnbc in 2000 and
it was the beginning of this incredible
five-year period of news i got there um
it's just kind of back to the future but
uh during the
biden i'm sorry during the gore bush
presidential race and of course the
recount in florida and from that uh
before long we were you know staring at
911 the invasion of afghanistan the
invasion of iraq that was on that really
brief period of time and i was principal
anchor for a lot of that and then kind
of worked my way across the river uh to
nbc news and you know weekend today uh
weekend nightly news uh dateline
and uh finally five years ago landed uh
in this job
and what would you say i mean that's
actually an incredible journey
the fact that you were you're doing so
much even from such a young age and you
kind of knew this
i am curious you know what
and this is this is sometimes hard for
people to answer because they don't want
to seem you know
they want to be modest about it but
please don't be modest
what what do you think uh you know
allowed you to kind of stand out and
eventually you know essentially have the
top job in broadcasting is at least from
my vantage point you know i played the
long game uh and i you know i just took
it a step at a time and really never
believed in you could be this like
overnight success without kind of paying
your dues and a lot of people that i
worked with talked about the importance
of paying your dues learning your craft
and just listening um
i was blessed with good mentors um you
know people who gave me sage advice and
who admonish me you know when i got
something wrong or the script didn't
make any sense or you know whatever it
was and i just tried to give everything
in in each job and then opportunities
would present themselves you know one
guy i worked for said um
you've got to be ready when doors open
because doors open at times you don't
expect um circumstances you don't expect
but you got to be ready to walk through
them that's kind of what my philosophy
has always been i've always said to
people um you know before i got this job
i was anchoring uh three jobs at nbc
news and i said
sometimes we're so busy climbing the
ladder
that we failed to like stop and pause on
a run and kind of look out and enjoy the
view
and you know i was a place um you know
that wasn't necessarily the top of the
game but for me i was really enjoying
what i was doing and so when the
opportunity came to anchor nightly news
i was prepared to walk through that door
um but at the same time i was you know i
was perfectly happy doing what i was
doing before i love covering news you
know i love you know
taking my personal curiosity and making
that uh my profession and i just you
know every every move has been i've been
tickled by it it's been hey this is
great it's a new opportunity a new
chance but i try to think of that you
know if that's the last job i had it's a
great job
and what do you think you know when you
look at other people young people
especially who are coming through the
ranks maybe you know
the 20 to 30 years before you know a
earlier version of yourself
where do you sometimes look at people
like okay that that that that that
youngins gonna make something out of
themselves because of x y and z and that
person's probably not doing it the right
way
yeah i do see you know there's i mean
when i whenever i meet someone who says
i want to be an anchor i'm like uh you
know what you want to be is you want to
be a reporter
another mentor i had that you know being
a reporter is the highest calling of
what we do and i say that to say this
that
when i'm sitting on that set every night
um you know yes it's prestigious it's
the top of the game you know it pays
more money and a lot of good things
about it but the most rewarding and
interesting and fascinating moments of
my career have not been sitting at an
anchor desk they've been out on the
field with camera crews and a pen and
pad and
you know fighting deadlines and whatever
hurricanes or you know toxic leaks
whatever the story is just being there
and covering the story that's what we do
i am always going to be a reporter first
as i said being an anchor it's the big
deal it's a celebrated job very cool to
get my name on the wall and all that
stuff
but it's all about it's all about the
art of reporting
do you still get to do uh some of that
reporting is that you know is that part
of your deal that you'll you'll be able
to maybe do some travel or do some
investigative uh type reporting
i do i am
one of the hallmarks of this show is we
take it on the road a lot for big
stories be it a natural disaster or
terrorists or attacks or you know big
big stories it's been difficult for us
to do that uh during the pandemic you
know traveling and you know and
quarantines and things of you know make
things different i did travel though um
you know to
minneapolis um you know during the um
george floyd story
we had traveled to texas for the funeral
there so we've gotten out um some but
you know we're we're still making the
adjustments but yeah i still like to get
out and tell stories and you know i
still work for for dateline i'm sorry i
just hit the camera um you know i still
do uh
dateline projects i'm working on one
right now um so that's that's what i
love to do and like all of us we're kind
of figuring out you know what's possible
how do we adjust
um you know
how we work uh in this pandemic but
we're figuring it out
and and there's a there's an interesting
question it's kind of related to that um
from facebook ellen h ullman uh and you
know i guess the context for this is you
know the news when you watch the news
you learn about
you know if if god forbid a plane goes
down or something bad happens or you
know death counts from the pandemic that
tends to be oftentimes like the leading
news um
but the question from alan is can we
have some good news shows too wouldn't
that be amazing
is there kind of a movement maybe to try
to surface you know not just the seven
really bad things that happen in the
world but maybe you know get people in a
good mood and i say that actually my mom
i think is addicted to the news and
sometimes it it gets to her i think no i
listen i i tell people all the time they
look at me really i say you know there
are days that i do the newscasts and i
walk out of the studio wow that was
tough like nobody lived in that in that
broadcast um they're you know we can't
obviously dictate i mean some days are
just super heavy but what we can do
is try and
have an arc of stories in the broadcast
and that's what we aim to do so yes
there will be you know whatever the top
story is um there may be you know then
stories are dealing with the particular
issues going on but we always like to
end the broadcast on something uplifting
some story you know we have with
different franchises inspiring america
is one of them and stories where you
know people are going above and beyond
they are taking on an issue by
themselves they are reaching out to
their fellow man and we you know i've
i've had people stop me and and ask
about that i love those stories at the
end and sometimes i see you you know you
tears in your eyes and yeah that happens
i'm a big crier sometimes um but i think
it's really important that we
find ways as often as we can again we
can't always dictate what the news day
will bring but find ways to kind of
center people on the good that we all
share that you know we hear so much
about the divisiveness in this country
and it is real um but there's also you
know just a lot of people who aren't
asking what your political stripes are
and they just want to help and they just
want to make a difference in this world
and and it's part of our job to
recognize them
yeah no it makes a lot of sense and i
mean related to that i mean this is a
really interesting question from
facebook fay marie
how do you keep up with what's important
yet not get overwhelmed by the volume of
news out there
um okay i'm just gonna tell is it faye
is that the person
faye
okay
sometimes i don't watch
um and i say i couldn't say that but
there i i you know during the when we
were first going through the beginning
of this pandemic you know i would have
friends you know say things like that i
can't handle it and you start to worry
about you know people seriously about
people's ability to to deal with this
and i would say
sometimes you just got to walk away from
it
you've got to turn off the tv and that's
the last message i know you would want
to hear from me and i hope you'll watch
me and then turn it off later uh but
what i mean by i don't mean to be
flipping but i think you do have to give
yourself a breather and and and
sometimes take it in in small doses um
you know we've been through some some
really difficult times we've put in the
pandemic um
the protests in the streets you know
struggling the black lives matter
movement um these are all important
things that we're struggling with in
different ways you know you've got the
the politics firing at us right now you
need to be informed you can't you know
you can't
you can't totally unplug
but but take breaks give yourself a
moment and try and digest these things
it's helpful to me um believe it or not
there's sometimes you know during the
day when i'm working of course i have to
be plugged in but there are some
weekends where i say you know i'm gonna
take the morning off now i have my phone
if something big happens you know i can
watch i get this text alert still i know
what's going on in the news but i do
give myself breathers and i think it
could be healthy
yeah i couldn't agree more and i think
if anything it can give you more
perspective if you have a breather you
can digest it and think about it more as
a historian than someone you know just
caught up in in the moment so it makes a
ton of sense uh you know there's another
question i think from people hearing
your i think pretty impressive narrative
especially in how much
motivation and how kind of an agency you
exercise when you're young this is from
youtube
wakrina m says you found your passion
pretty early what advice do you give for
kids regarding passionate careers what
should they look for how do they know
i think i had several several passions
you know music is one of my other
passions i'm a bass player and
i used to play in a band i say used to
we're not able to get together anymore
um but i you know i was blessed to you
know be raised by you know two wonderful
parents who
who basically instilled this idea that
we can do anything and that um you don't
have to take no for an answer and that
you can live your dreams and they were
very supportive of me and
so i never i never really questioned
whether i could do anything and i don't
say that from a point of arrogance but
it was a sense of if i apply myself if
this is really what i want to do um then
i can do it and then you know i would
spend so much time studying uh i wanted
to be on the radio so i would sit this
is it sounds a little pathetic now but
as a you know 15 16 year old i sit in my
bedroom with um well a record player
um a tape recorder and a microphone and
a newspaper and i would play radio i
would um
i would talk up a record you know i'd
give the weather sacramento weather is
going to be high of 75 today at a low of
55. we got more coming up but first we
got a song from whoever it was and i
would do the whole dj thing and then go
locate let's take a news break right now
and i would give the headlines
um i would this is terrible i used to
take uh you know unsanitary now but i
would take
pencils and put up my mouth and work on
my addiction and then in high school um
i got a chance to do the morning
announcements every day i was the guy
uh
that would you know it was the cordova
lancers so good morning lancers it's 8
30 and here's what's happening spanish
club is meeting in room e2 you know
after school today uh soccer has been
canceled whatever i would do that whole
thing and then i would
because i was in this whole dj mode i
would try and do it like a real radio
newscast um and so it would always end
you know and and that's what's happening
it's 8 38 and you're up to date and that
was my thing so you know the warrior
total nerd i was my goodness
what did your friends did your friends
give you
were your friends like yeah i know that
guy or did they give you a hard time
because you they thought hey this guy's
you know sounding like a real dj no i
think people got into i mean at least
they told me they got it i don't know
maybe they were talking behind my back
but uh but but it's it's a long question
but the idea was man i
this is not what i wanted to do and and
i knew i was gonna have to you know
figure it out and so you know i got
books and i listened and you know to
radio stations i would um i remember
going down to los angeles big market
with my tape recorder and recording all
the big radio stations there and then
taking them back and studying them um
that was really you know how i kind of
lived out this fashion
wow no i think that's a huge takeaway
for kids i mean anyone any young person
listening is just get deep in whatever
you're trying to do and
i guess if it doesn't resonate you know
find something else but yeah that's
that's i mean that's a wonderful people
a lot of people are asking about your
bass playing i mean do you still play
bass and i mean do you literally like
show up at gigs and like on bass it's
lester holt also anchor of the nightly
news well
i was listening to a band and i and
suddenly the bass stood out to me
and i said i love that sound and i i
decided i wanted to play bass and once
again this you know mr obsessive here um
i saved up some money from from
delivering uh papers and i went to a
pawn shop in downtown sacramento i
bought this you know cheap base and a
couple of books
and went on and taught myself the bank
and started playing in the junior high
jazz band and jazz choir and then i did
that in high school and uh
part of college as well so i play um
i play electric bass um and i play the
the big upright bass as well
uh i did jay i had a friend that used to
do gigs here in manhattan he'd ask me to
come sometimes and join him and you know
sit in on a set and back them up on base
and sometimes it was very fun because
they would announce the group you know
during the break and they'd stay in on
base you know lester holt you can see
people in the audience go oh my god that
is him you know not expected before we
there and then a couple years ago we
formed a band at nbc um we call
ourselves the rough cuts because most of
the members are video editors from
dateline nbc but we're all nbc folks and
we would sneak out on
you know monday tuesday mornings go to a
studio in midtown manhattan and rehearse
and we would do um you know gigs here in
town from time to time and uh we're
we're all kind of in this depression
because we obviously can't meet and play
right now but uh i always say you know
so so tv news is my passion right now i
always say it's important to have
something else in your life though
because i never want to be i never want
this to define me that oh he is the
anchorman it's what i do
but
i'm also the musician and there's other
facets of my life so i think it's it's
healthy for all of us to discover
something else in our lives so we're not
pitch and hold in
in some other role necessarily not that
i mind being the anchor
and what type of music do you play
um our band plays uh mostly pop and rock
covers um
funny thing is jazz is kind of my main
thing jazz and pop so i was never a big
rocker so when i got together with this
group they started you know throwing out
these songs
and fortunately i have a really good ear
and i can pick things up pretty quickly
but a lot of them i've never heard of
we're playing songs i never heard of and
i come home and tell my wife that yeah
we're doing this song you know and
uh it's pretty good she goes yeah yeah
as as many discovered back in 1979 or
whatever um
so i always think the group has kind of
helped me embrace my inner rocker uh but
it's been it's been a lot a lot of fun
no i could i could only imagine so folks
who are regular viewers know that i used
to be in a band in high school but i i
suspect i was not as talented as
you are
i was the lead singer and singing is a
very generous term for what i did
but
it yeah it's i
not it was it was heavy metal now i'm
much more calm i do more like you know
folksy acoustic type stuff
one question there's a couple questions
on this dimension and you know i'm
curious because you know it seems like
the media generally has evolved over the
last several decades you know there's
kind of the walter cronkite era back in
the day
um
do you see that it has evolved do you
see that you know the media is kind of
the fourth estate as you know kind of
holding government accountable making
sure that our democracy is informed
you know with the polarization and
sometimes people kind of being able to
pick and choose what they get
where do you see
the where we are in that narrative for
for the role of media well i think our
role is still the same obviously to you
know especially at the at the network
level to kind of you know be the
newscast of record every night to kind
of tell you you know what's happening in
the world and get you focused at the
same time i recognize and understand our
influence isn't what it was when you
know i was a boy and watching the
evening programs
people have choices now they have
other distractions you have other ways
to get their news
i recognize by the time they sit down
with us you know at 6 30 eastern time
that they generally know the big stories
of the day they know there's something
going on with uh you know with whether
the post office can can handle ballots
and and they they know some horrible new
corona numbers came out
uh as a friend of mine told me he says
you know i watch you not to get the news
he says i want you to get your take on
the news um
my take being our take as a broadcast
you know the stories that we choose to
cover how we cover them the the
perspective we you know we try to offer
and and you know
to help people really understand the
importance of these things so on that
level um
you know i think we're we're still vital
but again you know it's not that idea of
you know the whole world has to kind of
stop at this time that said um
many a tv writer has tried to write off
the future of the network evening
programs but at the end of the day
there's still you know 20 million plus
people who are watching uh every night
and i think we've all seen big increases
in interest right now during this
particular you know trying time in the
country you know people are craving
facts and information
um you know we did take um
i mean let's be honest we did you know
take
you know some some
cheap shots from from on high about you
know our business and the integrity of
journalists journalism in this country
but i think we have risen above that um
i think that people recognize that uh
you know they need these broadcasts to
really you know deliver the facts and
and to help understand and sort out you
know really really noisy environment out
there of information that's flying at
you from all different directions some
true some not
no absolutely i do think that the kind
of the evening broadcast
news
is kind of the still the go-to if you
know what you really can't sense the
bias that you can in and some other
things that you can get um either on
cable or or in the internet generally
you know just maybe one one last
question uh you know we're obviously in
interesting times you are
it's your job to be the observer and the
commentator on that for for our country
for the world
you know how are you thinking about the
times we're in what do you think folks
are going to say in 10 years about about
this time
yeah i had the conversation just a few
days ago i said you know when the
history of this pandemic is written
you're going to spend a lot of time
talking about you know how we managed to
find even that a way to divide us over
you know simple things like you know
wearing a face covering um you know
maintaining the ability to maintain some
physical distance between people i
wouldn't have thought those would be the
you know those would be issues we'd be
struggling as especially even with it
being tainted politically i think that
has has surprised me but it'll be part
of the history of how this is written i
think um
i think also we'll talk about
um misinformation
and how dangerous um it is you know to
democracy in general but certainly on an
issue that is so
you know life and death and i say that
without hyperbole i mean it is uh it's
truly a life-and-death matter and and
facts matter and words matter and
balance matter um and and so i think you
know that's going to be you know
part of how these times will be
described
i was maybe a little pollyannish i
thought when um when this pandemic broke
out i thought this would be one that
we would see the country really come
together and we have a large part i
don't want to you know discount that but
i think i i didn't see this as being as
divisive as it has turned out um but you
know it's part of the story we'll
continue to cover it um you know we as
one of the franchises we do facts over
fear that's one of our guiding
principles of how we cover uh the
pandemic and we will march forward
no that's that's super helpful really
good context well well lester thank you
so much uh once again i'm self-conscious
this whole time that i'm i'm so homebrew
compared to what you do uh but this is a
real treat and a real honor to be able
to talk to you about you know that all
of these things well so i've been
impressed by what you do for a very long
time and i appreciate the interest
always fun to come out and talk about
what we do we're very proud of
you know our operation and love to show
it often folks
great no thank you so much lester all
right cheers
well thanks everyone for joining again
hopefully you enjoyed that as much as as
i as i did um i am curious you know
lester didn't mention which pop songs he
plays i i maybe i'll i'll do some
follow-up i'm i am curious and there's
it looks like there's some requests for
people to hear me sing maybe at some
point uh although i won't sing the songs
i sang in high school i'll i'll do
something much more gentle but um
hopefully you enjoyed today's live
stream and i look forward to seeing you
all next week uh where were we promised
to have a whole bunch of uh more
interesting guests just like what we saw
this week thanks everyone have a good
weekend
you